hello and welcome to this video playgro
Massa Chamberlain to check that Gavriel
off okay so I need to really win games
yeah two or three sixty this is terrible
but they're playing really badly last
couple of games so very well deserved is
writing so let's let's see what i can do
is Chamberlain I should just play I'm
playing a save game here just being
solid solid and quick I had the same
thing earlier against sooner book hands
on yeah that's a very sound line for
black but yeah I just I just want the
very safe game you ever played row I'm
fine I just want to stop the bleeding
don't want to do anything fancy just
play normal moves and see what happens
so yeah doubling
yeah I know that it's not very exciting
but the last couple of games I really
and played atrociously bad badly so I
just want something simple him
ok
I wonder hmm well it's nothing nothing
great yet if you takes mmm yeah but it's
also it's not very exciting he tries to
put most of my policy on light squares
and play against my bishop but I don't
have to trade now don't have to trade
the rook I mean
look the 80 may be replicated doesn't it
isn't too much either check
yeah I know it's boring but i wanted a
solid game and it was a little bit too
solid
can't see going g4 check
yeah it is very Jewish not not much
going on at all DRA Arthur
hmm yeah he wants to do something yeah
okay maybe I let's try something I'm not
I'm not really great at sitting around
myself so yeah check and so it says so
that i can try like this King up here
yeah probably doesn't lead to anything
good if I now go back to d7 maybe
yeah whenever I go down he would start
to pick up pawns himself so rookie six
rupee won't take stakes and I cannot
cover b4 awesome it doesn't really lead
to anything ready can go clean g6 at
five now that's something that I should
have thought of yeah well okay if he
goes there I have roped your seven so
it's not really an issue I think check
this is the problem yes okay check check
okay I should have just done nothing but
this is my usual problem I'm not really
great at doing nothing in a in a totally
dead position usually try and try to do
something and then it blows up in my
face at least I've got the h-bond check
so how to do this age five I'm pretty
quick here with the pawn check
guard go age seven but I can do this
threatening age 7 h-7 what's the deal
and don't get it what's happening here
Black Rose is very strange not a game
that I should have won yeah I know I
just want to play it very safely and go
to go to completely prospectus position
check I thought you would keep the night
on check me now check here this is this
is very Jewish until check mo I felt I
should allow King to just King King up
and here i'm having trouble quite quite
clearly chan yeah chance I didn't really
understand why he didn't he play this
this this is what i was thinking and
here i didn't see much going much going
for me check this is actually not that
clear the engine Cessna this is equal
maybe I'm quick enough with the asian
porn I've got the King cut off and does
this took long time check but still it
only here here's the issue he has to go
King f6e and this position and not this
one which just allows promotion maybe
that was a mouse lip ya hear this oh
yeah actually can stop those can stop
the pawn yeah yeah and okay this is a
job I'm quick enough them yeah this is
the correct result and that that
shouldn't be the winner should be should
be a draw at the end why should lose
actually I need to in the meantime fine
in the middle of it I was I was also
very much lost at one point of course
okay well thanks for watching